bonjour pauline clément merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous ce matin en direct sur
rt france est-ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer cette fascination de certains
russes pour napoléon alors que en france
la célébration de ce bicentenaire
suscite plutôt la polémique
bonjour tout d'abord en russie comme l'a
dit un petit peu plus tôt ils ont une
admiration pour napoléon comme politique
comme de guerre et surtout fait pour son
parcours le fait qu'il est commencée
depuis tout jeune qu'il ait parcouru
toutes ces étapes ensuite d'une certaine
manière les les russes ont toujours
beaucoup plus apprécié est rappelé en
même temps ou embellissement il ya une
tendance à dire ils ont déjà les russes
et en titres est fier sans jamais été
complètement envahi il n'y a qu'à
demander à l'ue d'ici les allemands avec
elle n'a revanche les français ont été
coupées hier deux il ya un napoli en
sont on vise pas la voix nous avons tout
ce qui n'est vraiment pas les citer pour
son parcours et par là de la manière ou
en recommençant tous les héros à devenir
un encore maîtres de la la famille assez
intéressante
c'est ça qui suscite en sommes si elle
surtout exemple oui d'ailleurs il y a il
y à il ya des reliques de napoléon dans
des musées en russie suite à cette
campagne
ah oui il en sort sur la très fier il ya
aussi d'aider des personnes qui
célèbrent napoléon en cette date 10 812
sa marque sa marque aussi une
début aussi pour la russie une certaine
certains disent que napoléon à
participer à la réunification la russie
en quelque sorte
vous voulez dire que montpellier ou
encore unification j'ai pas à participer
à l'unification à l'édification de la
haye de la russie je ne suis pas je ne
suis pas alors on va pas je vais vous
poser une autre question justement sur
ce respect en tout cas de l'histoire par
les russes récemment encore là où vous
êtes même il y a eu l'enterrement de
dépouilles de soldats qui avaient
combattu justement de soldats français
qui avaient combattu pendant cette
campagne de russie en 1812
oui mais les francos les corps de france
est également est entré à trèbes a pour
mission et dans le reste des cérémonies
mais sa valeur viasna c'était en février
comment vous expliquez finalement que
napoléon soient plus respectés en russie
qu'en france vous comprenez la polémique
autour de la célébration ce bicentenaire
ici en france on a toujours les maîtres
et les gens qui nous ont le peut-être le
plus apporté sur tous passés par peur
c'était un homme qui était très très
très fort donc je pense qu'on a peur de
susciter d'intérêt pour éduquer l'autre
alors qu'en russie de l'invs est le
russe est née à angers par l'empa et 7
ce bicentenaire est ce qu'il est célébré
d'une façon ou d'une autre ou pas du
tout en russie si à l'arrivée des gens
qui font la reconstitution historique en
russie salue
pauvre petit vim donc c'est des
célébrations qui sont à mes mauvais
jérémy qui sont des eaux et aux
constructeurs et qu'ils en profitent
pour faire une expédition où ils
voyagent en peu de temps
donc merci regarder les événements en
lien avec ce genre de cet événement
merci beaucoup pauline clément d'avoir
répondu ce matin en direct et nous avoir
donné votre point de vue de russie
justement sur ce bicentenaire de
napoléon merci à vous